《红楼梦》第62回发生了一件小事。中经猜阴家宝玉生日得以其聚。家家三小姐汉春、立鼠众人生日,期间特意提到待遇的生日是2月12。跟花媳人属于同天生日。汉春笑到,到有些意思。一年十二个月,月月有几个生日。人多了便这等巧,也有三个一日,两个一日的。
大年初一日也不白过,大姐姐占了去,愿不得她福大,生日比别人就占先,又是太祖太爷的生日。过了登杰,就是老太太和宝姐姐,她们娘儿两个遇得巧。三月初一日是太太,初九日是梁儿哥哥,二月没人,习人道,二月十二是林姑娘,怎么没人,就只不是咱家的人。
汉春笑到,我这个记性是怎么了。宝玉笑指习人道,她和林妹妹是一日,所以她记得。
曹雪晴这么设置,显然是有用意的。否则她完全可以在汉春的对话里,将待遇2月的生日插入其中,没必要让汉春忘记平耳的生日。
这么做,当然是为了引出习人的那句解释,强调待遇习人同天生日这个事实。
有些读者无法理解这个设置,因为红楼素有,秦为待影,习为拆负的说法。
秦文才是林待遇的影子,就算是同天生日,似乎也应该是林待遇和秦文同天生日,才更加硬紧一些。
戴着这个疑问,我们翻语直地本红楼就会发现,秦为待影,习为拆负的说法,最早出现在假训本第8回,假保育大罪降云轩。
其因是,李莫莫吃了假保育留给秦文的豆腐皮包子,秦文愿言相告热的保育大怒,差点要去回名假母王父认,把自己的奶娘黏走。
此处有一段假训双行假批,写道是,奶母之已是意识长情,奶母之昏愧意识长情,然特于此处细写一回,与后文习秦苏劳搖搖一对,足见秦秦不如习秦原以,于为秦有灵风洗奶拆负真真不假。
诸君要注意,只验拆之所以认为秦有灵风,是因为在第8回礼,灵代与秦文先后跟李莫莫产生交集。
先是灵代与,在丽香院削移妈家的晚饭上,跟李莫莫成对台系。
李莫莫不让保育喝酒,带育偏偏怂勇保育喝。
等保育回到住处,秦文也不顾李莫莫的面子,将他吃豆腐皮包子的事,吸鼠都出,导致甲宝与大怒。
虽然最后没有黏走李莫莫,但甲宝与的压缓欠血却成了牺牲品,从甲宝与的贴山压缓明额中被替处。
因此,秦有灵风的说法是有具体情节硬设的。
直验摘是基于带秦两人对李莫莫的态度。
两人皆有灵压力耻,懒于为李莫莫遮掩,甚至直接表达对李莫莫的不满。
也正因此,直验摘才拿后来的习人做对比。
后文里,甲宝与给习人留了疏漏,也被李莫莫给吃了。
习人担心宝与生气,就谎称自己不喜欢吃苏漏,将矛盾熙灭在蒙牙状态。
所以只验摘认为,秦亲不如习亲原以。
单立足于第八回,确实是秦有灵风,意思不错。
可如果立足红楼全书,还要将应地认为秦为带引,则有些不合实意了。
因为后期的灵带域不断成长,完全变成了大家规秀。
坚压力耻挑人次的是越来越少。
甚至连赵一娘,灵带域都能礼貌招待。
故而学界对带域性情分析,有一个说法叫灵带域的性格逐渐保采化。
即,年轴后的带域不再监算刻薄,动者挑别人的谋病。
而称为与人为善和光统诚的大家小姐。
反观秦文,他的新高气澳已经定行,动者打骂压缓。
甚至有时候跟甲宝域也对着干。
第三是一回,秦文刷坏善故,保育出言责备。
秦文分明不占理,却说。
先时连那么样的玻璃钢毛脑碗,不知弄坏了多少,也没见个大切。
这毁则一把扇子就这么着了。
这也导致秦文成了一红院里,唯一一个差点被甲宝域亲自扭出去的压缓。
这种性格一直持续到他的结局。
第七是四回,货坚产超减大官员。
王夫任之所以对秦文产生反感情绪,
重染其中有王善保家的匪帮作碎,但不得忽略的一个因素是。
王夫任曾亲眼看见秦文,差着腰骂人,言行举指示分消章。
眼见为时,成了王夫任,验弃秦文的重要因素之一。
后期,秦有零封的唯一证明,只有王夫任的那句。
上次,我们跟了老太太进员逛聚,
有一个水蛇腰,销肩膀,眉眼又有些像你临妹妹的,正在那里骂小丫头。
但外表形象的相似,并不能代表人物综合品质的相访。
而且红龙梦里的金拆,多有融贸相似之处。
比如,乡林长得像秦可秦。
秦可秦又有,保拆之鲜艳五妹,带育之风流扭挪。
秦文又有几分像带育,这种融贸因素的重合并非罕见。
故而,秦为带引这个说法,继对也不对。
他只能代表某个时期的秦带形象,而不是一个放置全书而基准的结论。
所以,操学秦没有让带育秦文同天生日,以是本体和影子的平行关系。
而是让带育习人同天生日,这个设置有更加现实的思想考量。
单旧红龙梦前80回而言。
林带育是家府公认的宝尔奶奶,花习人则是家府公认的宝玉事歉。
故而第62回,看春历术重人生日,带习两人同天生日处,有邀线没批评价道。
带育为群会之冠习人姓花,结于2月12日,习云不是咱家人据中有眼。
看春历,倒是你两个同日,用倒自以为两家人,却同不是咱家人。
邀线的评价一真见写,习人自为带育不是咱家人,眼然是自己为假家人。
熟不知,他自己最终谁知公子无缘,嫁给了细子讲欲汉,也未能如愿成为咱家人。
故而这段描述,需要结合结局来观才能看到庙主。
同时,立足家宝玉的视角,他也将带育习人,是为自己未来的一切一切。
为此曹雪琴还设置了一箱类比,便是林带玉丧富,花西人丧牧。
家宝玉对二者的相同反应。
第十五回,家链的小四招儿回家传信,将名了林如海去世的消息。
曹雪琴专门记录了王西奉,假宝玉的不同反应。
奉解变问,回来做什么的,招儿到,二爷打发回来的。
林姑老爷是九月初三日四十没的,二爷带了林姑娘,同宋林姑老爷林到苏州,大约赶年底就回来。
二爷打发小的来报个信请安,逃老太太事下,还瞧瞧奶奶家里好,就把大谋衣服带几间去。
奉解到,你见过别人了没有,招儿到都见过了,说闭联盟退去。
奉解像宝玉笑到,你林妹妹可在咱们家住长了。
宝玉到了不得,想来这几日她不知哭的怎样呢,说着促没常看。
林如还去世,林带玉彻底论为孤儿,王西奉却以,林妹妹在咱家常住为思路,想着隐斗宝玉开心。
宝玉关心的却是带玉的伤情,二者高下立判。
于此类比的是第五十一回,习人的母亲并重,眼看就要不行了。
王西奉却把习人叫过来,让她打扮的丰富光光的。
因为习人此时已经被内定围准一鸟,代表着荣国府的脸面。
为此王西奉还专门省了习人衣上,连包行里的包袱都要拿最好的。
而当家宝玉得知,习人母亲并重的消息后,在习人离开之后,到晚间她的反应确试,
此时宝玉正做着纳闷,想习人之母不知是死是活。
等得知习人母亲去世的消息后,宝玉又祖父设悅,打点东西,前老默默去看习人,劝她少哭。
曹雪晴两次用奉劫宝玉的反应进行对比。
奉劫是智山室外,宝玉是体贴至极,这也是曹雪晴对着一切一切的平行描述。
如此看来,曹雪晴安排林代玉花习人同天生日,并非是随比写旧,而是有所谋话。
胸中有基州之大家,行文落笔往往如此。
红楼梦的成功,当真是一个伟大的作家,成就了一部伟大的作品。
今天的红楼解读就到这里,我们下个视频再会。